we are now one month away from hybrid
learning starting in the clark county
school district
lower elementary grade students are the
first to try attending class on campus a
couple of days a week while completing
digital course work as well
during the week a news now reporter
kristen drummond shows us the transition
effort
elementary school principals continue
working out logistics for their campuses
they're reviewing the most recent school
district questionnaire to find out which
students want to come back or not
now it's kind of the follow up to make
sure that
those results still match the intention
ryan lewis is the gerheim elementary
school principal
he tells me the ccsd survey shows a
split among his families
we have about 50 percent of our kids
that are having interest of coming back
however i will tell you that has
lessened a little bit
once they truly understand the number of
days that the kids would truly be on
campus
students choosing hybrid learning attend
class in a building twice a week
that adds up to less than 30 days on
campus the remainder of the school year
you've got to start somewhere and two
days a week is somewhere
parents like brittany provencher support
hybrid learning even with the likely
restrictions
making it an atypical school day even if
it is socially distant
even if they're eating their school
class lunch in the classroom you know
these kids need that little bit of
interaction i'm not sending my children
back
brandi hecht questions changing students
schedules we're opening so quick because
of mental health
but yet we're changing everything these
children have had
consistent for the last six months what
is that going to do to them
that change likely includes students not
getting the same teacher
a challenge lewis says he and his
colleagues aim to address
it's going to very build the building
depending on which students come back
and
who chooses to continue full-time
distance education kristin drummond 8
news now
principal lewis says the hybrid plan
will be the same across campuses but
expect
implementation of various schools as he
pointed out depending on the need of
students
as well as staff denise